[Music]
Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively dapper
and dazzling at the Deadpool 2 premiere
like by the way that Blake were the
Deadpool colors tonight I thought it was
a very dutiful look that is a dutiful
wife she went full I'd be wearing the
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again
kiss me like you miss me right this
weekend Deadpool 2 will go head-to-head
at the box office with the ladies of
book club well we chose for you here mr.
lively will show you are as if you show
us yours I called you when do you feel
most like mrs. Black Point no 24/7 I'm
mr. lively 24/7 and I'm happy about it
that's great another great gig
this one Ryan in a unicorn costume
singing in any classic on a Korean
competition show
[Music]
on that path Blake first what was her
thought on that I don't know what she
knew I was doing I don't know I think
she she knows that terrified of singing
in public so yeah so I invited my told
her I think she would have pushed me to
do it because I'm terrified
my daughter is young enough to think
that I have a good voice so oh that's
very nice of you but I yeah it's not
it's not my bags it's not the bread and
butter
[Music]
[Applause]